if you think fighting aliens is tough
try learning guitar
well that was a segue ten years ago
rocksmith redefined music learning by
introducing the first console game that
taught
millions how to play guitar whether
you're already an expert or just
starting out
rocksmith has an approach that's for
everyone a fun and interactive way to
learn guitar
playing your favorite songs and in the
decades since its release
our community and its impact have only
amplified
this year let's turn it up to 11 and see
what's next for rocksmith
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as famed as anything reached into
the walls it's all the fears
in the afternoon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
song fear
it's all for you
[Music]
a song for you
[Music]
i'm arthur von egel producer at ubisoft
san francisco
and rocksmith has truly been a dream
project for me
as a lifelong gamer and a touring
musician rocksmith is what i wish i had
when i started learning music and that's
why i'm thrilled to share
the next evolution of music learning
rocksmith plus a new interactive
music learning subscription service
available this year
learn how to play guitar and bass by
playing along to master recordings
of your favorite songs connect your
instrument to your pc
console or mobile device and get
real-time
feedback as you play connecting with
rocksmith plus
will be easier than ever now that you
can use your phone
as a microphone download the app log in
sync to rocksmith plus set it down and
play along
now acoustic players and electric
players with amps
can use rocksmith plus with no extra
gear needed
it's a game changer
[Music]
and we're excited to reveal rocksmith
plus will have a
huge amount of songs at launch all songs
in the library will have
chord charts that will be perfect for
rhythm players who want to learn the
foundation of a song
to hum and strum along to we'll still
have the note for note
authentic arrangements for players that
want to play songs
exactly how the artists originally
played them and each week
we release a steady stream of new
authentic arrangements
to keep growing that portion of the
library we're also introducing
the rocksmith workshop a new tool that
lets users
create and add their own arrangements
for songs we've licensed
your subscription will give you access
to all those songs
more content than ever before including
genres beyond rock
we'll have pop hip hop country latin r
b all sorts of metal sub-genres will
have music from
all over the world from big stars to
indie darlings
it's the most diverse song library ever
seen
in music learning software rocksmith
plus will still have our proven practice
features like adaptive difficulty and
riff repeater which let you practice
and learn at your own pace or slow down
and repeat tricky parts until you master
them
we've improved those features in
rocksmith plus and are introducing new
ones
beginner and intermediate players will
benefit from more
personalized learning thanks to an
enhanced recommendation system
and more robust progress tracking
players won't just see their growth on a
single song
they can now monitor their progress
technique by technique
across the board and overall offer a
better sense of how you're improving
over time advanced players will be happy
to know for introducing a new
rocksmith tablet review that way you
could take advantage of rocksmith plus
song library and practice tools in a
format that's familiar
and one that will hone your tab reading
skills we're excited to announce that
you can register for a chance
to participate in our closed beta right
after the show
visit our website at rocksmith.com to
get an early look at rocksmith plus
and help us test and create the future
of music learning
thank you so much to the amazing fans
who have enjoyed
and supported rocksmith over the past 10
years
let's jam together with rocksmith plus
for another 10.
[Applause]
register now for a chance to play the
rocksmith plus beta
[Music]